Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Die fünfzigste Sendung, so eine Art Jubiläum. Ist beeindruckt? Ja. Ist gut.
Irgendwie wird das ja auch immer professioneller, wenn wir das hier anschaue. Findest du die auch? Hat schon so ein bisschen was von Fernsehstudio.
Weil du jetzt hier eine Webcam aufgestellt hast.
Na ja, ich meine, das äh ne? Ist unser Einstieg äh in die Zukunft, einundzwanzigste äh Jahrhundert, Teil zwei.
Der Video-Podcast.
Ja D, also hier einfach die Studiosituation, ne? Es fehlen einfach nur noch so äh,
Kameras oder was vielleicht auch sehr gut kommen würde, wie so ein so ein Bullet-Time-Effekt. Müssen wir mal gucken, ob man das ein Audio irgendwie nach äh gestellt bekommt. Was schon Bullettime, Matrix und so. Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Ja, ja, klar, ja.
Ne? Ich könnte dich so mit mit Wattebäuschen äh beschmeißen und dann sieht man so, dann rotiert das dann immer so, genau. Ja.
Ja, nee, klar. Äh, kann man ja ein Dolpis Surround dann machen.
Oh, genau. Bullettime in.
Bullettime in, ja und ein queke Level brauchen wir auch.
Na gut, fünfzigste Sendung, äh das hat uns so ermattet, der Gedanke, dachten wir uns gleich, holen wir uns äh auch gleich nochmal äh Verstärkung äh herein.
Für ein Update aus dem Süden. Und wir sagen hallo zu äh Thomas.
Hallo.
Live zugeschaltet aus unserem äh Korrespondentenstudio in Wien.
Ja, hinter mir ist der Stefans Dom, ja, wir sehen irgendwie die Wiener das Wiener Stadtbild, alles verschneit.
Ja, sehr romantisch.
Thomas steht quasi in unserem äh Hauptstadtstudio äh es ist wie in die Hauptstadt von Österreich.
Nackt nackt vor dem.
Habe ich Glück gehabt. Ich habe ja null Ahnung, ne von äh von überhaupt Geografie, ne, aber insofern ich habe sehr wenig Ahnung von Geografie, ja.
Und, und, und. Hauptstädte gehört für dich zur Geographie, ja. Okay.
Täte ja weil dafür muss man ja wissen, wo sie sind.
Ja, das ist aber nicht unbedingt.
Nee, ich bin, ich bin nicht so besonders Firmen im äh im Bereich der Geografie, äh da ich fühle mich da nicht nicht so äh.
Wir können ja die nächsten Sendungen immer eröffnen, ich sage ein Land und du äh sagst, was du denkst, was die Hauptstadt ist.
Nee, das äh geht schief.
Na, aber ist zumindest unterhaltsam.
Bin da nicht so, bin dann nicht so gut drin.
So so. Na ja gut, aber Hauptsache äh Hauptsache unterhaltsam, denn äh da wir euch ja ansonsten hier mit den trockenen Themen der Nestpolitik befeuern, muss man auch ansonsten noch ein bisschen Humor bewahren.
Ich habe ich habe Humor gezeigt. Was? Ich habe Humor gezeigt woanders allerdings.
Hast du? Wo denn?
Ich war äh zusammen mit Rosa Gast bei wir müssen reden. Sein Podcast, da habe ich äh habe ich glaube ich,
Luxus, eine äh Berliner Aktivistin. Äh wir waren da als Doppelpaket äh zu Gast in in äh dieser Sendung und haben ein bisschen so erzählt vom.
Jetzt Politik.
Und Aktivismus und so Kram, ne? Viereinhalb Stunden Sendung, also da ist äh relativ viel erzählt worden.
Ah, verstehe, na gut, das können wir ja dann nochmal reinschmeißen, ne?
Genau, das war, glaube ich, teilweise Unterhalter und ich muss äh ich muss üblicherweise, wenn ich ein ein äh Geschenk bekomme von meiner Amazon-Wunschliste, dann äh schreibe ich eine E-Mail oder einen Brief zurück,
Ich hab diese Woche zwei bekommen die aber von meinem Arbeitskollegen geöffnet wurden,
und ähm der hat die Kartons weggeworfen, deswegen stand wusste ich nicht mehr, wer die Absender waren. Äh deshalb danke ich äh für,
Die beiden sehr schönen Geschenke, die ich diese Woche bekommen habe. Den beiden Absendern und muss mich dafür entschuldigen, dass äh ich leider eure Namen nicht habe. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr nochmal kurz eine E-Mail schreibt, um euch zu erkennen, zu.
Schickt einfach noch ein Buch.
Den schickt man noch. Müsst ihr nochmal schicken.
Gut, let's git äh series, womit äh fangen wir denn heute an?
Ja mit was überhaupt nicht humorvoll.
Ja, ist doch gut, passt doch.
Mit äh Trojanersoftware.
Oha. Ja. Schon wieder.
Wir hatten da ja bereits äh einige,
Sendungen zu zu dem Problem des äh oder zu dem zu dem zu der Thematik des äh Staatstrojaners,
Und ich hatte ja bereits äh da äh kann ich ja sogar sagen, da habe ich ja recht gehabt,
ich hab recht gehabt ich hatte ja angekündigt dass ich damit dass ich fest davon ausgehe dass Deutschland sich.
Da auch noch einkauft.
Da einkauft und zwar vor allem etwas aus dem Hause Gamma, ähm die es sind also diejenigen, die,
von führenden Diktatoren empfohlen werden, so hieß glaub ich auch damals der Sendungstitel.
Was mich auch hallo Steffi.
Hallo Steffi von führenden Diktatoren empfohlen oder so, ich mache da nochmal die Links in die Shownotes,
also jene, die in den Diktaturen zur Anwendung kommen und da zuletzt in Bareien dann darüber gestolpert sind, dass die Aktivisten, die Myware, die ihnen dazugesendet wurde, äh zur Analyse gegeben haben,
und damit diesen Trojaner äh.
Etwa enttarnt haben, was aber offensichtlich dem Modell der Infektion dann auch, wie von mir, äh prognostiziert jetzt kein so großes äh,
Problem äh verschafft hat, das Zeug ist also nach wie vor weiterhin im Einsatz. Die hatten sich auch dagegen vorbereitet. Also je genau jene Firma, die vermutlich die äh die Kernkompetenz hier hat äh im Bereich der des Trojanerbaus,
Ähm kann jetzt auch das BKA zu seinen Kunden zählen. Das heißt, äh die Software, die wir,
in in den Unrechtsregimes, in der Anwendung sehen, die für die interessiert sich jetzt auch das BKA und zwar um damit die Lücke zu füllen,
die bis sie eine Eigenentwicklung haben. Ja, sie gehen irgendwie davon aus, dass sie äh,
Also sie haben drei Millionen Euro und dreißig neue Stellen aus, also dreißig, drei Millionen Euro veranschlagt und dreißig neue Stellen ausgeschrieben für eine Eigenentwicklung eines,
Staatstrojaners. Du möchtest BKA haben?
Ähm diese Stellenausschreibung ist immer also die ist immer noch online, da wird regelmäßig, guckt da einer drauf und äh sagt ah guck mal, die ist ja immer noch online. Die haben immer noch keinen gefunden oder so, ja, ähm.
Zahlen jetzt auch eher so Polizistentarife, nicht? Also es ist äh.
Streng nach äh wie halt Tarifvertrag, ne?
Hier irgendwas.
Dreizehn oder so was, ja. Wirst du jetzt nicht reich, ey. Aber ähm,
Genau, da Sie also davon ausgehen, dass Sie das jetzt nicht äh innerhalb der nächsten Wochen äh fertig kriegen. Wir wollen Sie quasi für die für den Zeitraum eine andere Lösung haben und da hat das Kompetenzzentrum
Informationstechnische Überwachung im Bundeskriminalamt,
Äh ein äh Dokument äh dem Haushaltsausschuss vorgelegt, äh dass unter äh der Geheimhaltungsstufe Verschlusssache nur für den Dienstgebrauch stand und vor einigen Tagen dann auf Netzpolitik org,
gelegt wurde und da geht's also darum, dass sie von der Firma ähm Gamma,
oder mit der Firma Gamma zusammenarbeiten und da ein Produkt gerade prüfen lassen, ja? Und.
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht irgend so ein wirres Gerücht, sondern es gibt da sozusagen wirklich so ein Dokument, äh an dem das äh ganz gut ablesbar ist, dass es auch tatsächlich stattfindet.
Ja, sie haben nämlich eine, die externe Firma CSC, äh damit beauftragt die Einhaltung der rechtlichen Vorgaben zu prüfen und ähm.
Das für eine Firma?
Ja, das äh CSD Solutions, äh den gehört,
laut äh einiger Artikel, die Firma oder gehörte die Firma Dünnkorb und die hatte so etwas Ähnliches gemacht wie Blackwater.
Also seltener äh Organisation sozusagen.
Ähm,
Also ich habe einen eine Aufklärung über die Firma Dünkop äh in einer Aufgabe über die Firma Dünkob heißt es, Dünnkorb wird nicht gerne mit Blackwater und KBA verglichen, aber die Firma macht genau das Gleiche.
Wegen des schlechten Images.
Genau und das äh BKA hat dann auch die äh Anschaffung des äh des Finn Fischer äh bestätigt,
Ja, also da gibt's jetzt gar keinen Zweifel mehr dran,
Hat aber ähm gesagt, dass der dass die Software im Moment oft eben nicht den rechtlichen Vorgaben entspricht und daher auch noch nicht zum Einsatz gekommen ist.
Man hat sie jetzt erstmal, kannst du in etwa einschätzen, was da so die äh Kostenraben sind, in dem man sich da bewegt so als Staat, wenn man da bei so einer Firma aufläuft?
Das kann ich ähm deshalb nicht einschätzen, weil die Preise, also es gab ja äh als die in Ägypten
die äh die Ministerien gestürmt haben,
irgendwie auch Verträge. So kam das ja überhaupt jemals ans ans Licht oder ins größere Licht der Öffentlichkeit. Da waren dann Verträge über die, über quasi die Lizenzen oder so,
ähm die Preise, die da da drauf standen, erschien mir ein bisschen gering.
Und was stand da so für Preise drauf?
Ich weiß es deshalb nicht mehr genau, aber es war irgendwie war, waren jetzt nicht waren jetzt nicht unbedingt Millionenbeträge. Ähm was man dazu sagen muss, diese ähm,
Es scheint ja tatsächlich so zu sein, dass äh Gamma dann auch den den Commanden Control Server äh selber unterhält, also den Server, an den diese Trojaner dann äh berichten.
Das Zentrum des Botnetzes sozusagen.
Genau das Zentrum des Sportnetzes und da gibt's sicherlich noch einige äh datenschutzrechtliche Probleme, die sie haben, aber äh die Meldung steht und es war natürlich zu erwarten, das sind eben die, die es am besten können.
Okay, also das BKA kauft jetzt dieselbe Software, die auch die anderen unterdrücker Regime haben, weil Deutschland kann ja da technologisch nicht hinter der dritten Welt äh zurückstehen
und äh lässt das Ganze überprüfen von so einer Firma, die auch so Dinge macht wie Blackwater, also irgendwie so bezahlte Söldner in Krisenherden, die sich nicht an staatliche Vorgaben halten müssen, zumindest nicht so lange, wie es nicht
der Zeitung steht.
Zu der zu der Firma CSC, da würde ich jetzt nochmal äh halte ich mich jetzt ein bisschen zurück, weil ich da nicht so viel zu recherchiert habe, aber auf jeden Fall, man sucht nicht lange äh nach CSC ähm,
äh ohne irgendwie sehr komische Verstrickungen dazu finden.
Die scheinen auf jeden Fall auch weit verbreitet zu sein. Gibt's auch äh in Österreich, sehe ich gerade.
Dann hat äh der äh Chef von Gamma äh,
über Netzpolitik org. Das ist ganz interessant. Also Andre hat ähm Andre Meister hat da hat diese Sachen alle äh recherchiert und veröffentlicht, der auch öfter bei uns zu Gast war. Äh und auch sein wird in Zukunft noch. Ähm,
Kontakt zu zu Martin Münch und der antwortet ihm auch. Also er kriegt immer die Statements von.
Ist jetzt wer?
Der berüchtigte Chef von Gamma,
und auch einer der und so,
oder ursprünglich weiß gar nicht genau, ob das jetzt immer noch macht, aber der hat das geht auf jeden Fall auch auf ihn zurück. Und er hat gesagt, äh er gibt natürlich keine Auskunft zu bestehenden oder zukünftigen Kunden,
Äh noch wie diese unsere Produkte nutzen, um Straftäter zu überführen. Ähm,
Ja, ist natürlich ganz klar, dass er, dass er dazu keine Auskunft geben kann äh und sagt, äh hinzu kommt zudem, dass wir derzeit,
aktiven Gesprächen mit verschiedenen Menschenrechtsorganisationen sind, um einen möglichen Code of Condact für Firmen wie unsere in dieser Branche zu entwerfen
und durchzusetzen. Und wir wollen diese Gespräche durch Veröffentlichung von interner nicht in Gefahr bringen.
ja? Ähm laut es scheint also,
Aus Deutschland scheint es keine NGO zu sein, die sich mit äh mit Gamma unterhält, man darf gespannt sein, was für ein Code of Contact, also,
Call of Connect ist ja sowas wie eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung.
Das funktioniert ja super.
Ethische Prinzipien in den äh in die Staatstrojanerindustrie ähm.
Pionage mit menschlichem Ansitz. Ja. Ja. Mhm.
PR-Probleme lösen.
Genau, also das äh das das riecht sehr nach äh PR Probleme lösen. Das Interessante ist, äh lädt er sich jetzt tatsächliche NGOs ein oder hat er schon seine eigene gegründet, ja, die,
die äh ja also ähm kann ich jetzt gar nichts zu sagen, weil äh äh ne, dass diese Gespräche möchte er natürlich nicht äh verletzen,
Aber ähm ich meine, jeder äh der MJM ist sicherlich nicht dumm und äh jeder hätte ihm natürlich nach den nach der Veröffentlichung der,
äh des Funktionsumfangs mit der Analyse natürlich genau zu zu einem solchen kleinen,
PR-Schritt äh geraten. Er hatte sich, hat sich auch vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten bei irgendeiner großen Zeit nicht weiß gar nicht mehr genau, was das war, wo er dann so,
sich beklagte, dass er ja für das ähm,
wenn ihr eine Frau kennenlernt und die seinen Namen kugelt, äh sie ihn nie wieder anruft dabei, äh kämpft er ja für, ne, für die Freiheit und den Frieden äh gegen Pädophile und Nazis,
ungefähr. Das ist das Selbstverständlich. Ich finde das auch wichtig, dass äh durchaus auch mal äh so zur zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, ja.
Gut, nehmen wir das äh zur Kenntnis.
Ich meine.
Gibt's Österreich hat das aber noch nicht äh äh nachgemacht, ne? Das muss jetzt in Deutschland erstmal wieder gemacht werden, damit das dann Österreich auch alle toll finden oder gibt's da hast du da schon mal was von gehört, Thomas.
Na ja, Bundestrojaner war ja bei uns aufgrund dieses sehr lustigen Leaks, äh dass wir überhaupt draufgekommen sind, dass unser Staat den auch gekauft hatte. Ähm wenn ihr euch erinnert, nachdem der CCC diesen Bundestrojaner veröffentlicht hat
hat äh ja irgendwer mal eine Falschmeldung rausgehauen mit ja und der wird auch noch in ganz vielen anderen Ländern verwendet. Und dann hat die Betreiberfirma ja gesagt, nein, das stimmt nicht, wir sind nur in Deutschland, Österreich und noch anderen Ländern.
Ach, guck ab.
Ging auf die äh hedonistische Internationale zurück.
Ja und wir suchen immer noch ähm nach äh ja Festplattenrechnen, wo solche Trojaner zum Einsatz gekommen sind. Wir haben leider noch nie was gefunden.
Das war aber äh digitals, ne, was äh in Österreich zum, genau, ja. Da gab's einen Fake äh Twitter-Account, der äh,
irgendwie solche Sachen dann.
Verbreitet hat.
Wird übrigens auch behandelt in in einem in einem Vortrag beim,
Hätte ich schon fast gesagt, Weltkongress der der Computer Chaoten.
Internationale.
Äh vom neunundzwanzigsten Politikhaken, da wird das auch nochmal äh behandelt, dieser dieser Twitter-Account und wie dann digital offensichtlich durch Zufall zugegeben hat, äh Österreich zu seinen Kunden.
Wir verlinken, wir verlinken. Gut, äh haben wir das durch das Thema, ja, ne?
Ja, also ähm hoffen wir's. Also es wird, es bleibt spannend. Wir werden jetzt mal sehen, also dieser, dieser ist ja sehr, sehr ausführlich,
bin mal sehr gespannt wie sie den zu Recht stutzen ich hatte das ja glaube ich damals schon gesagt dass ich damit rechne dass es so eine Art BRD Edition mit der Hälfte der Features und dem doppelten Preis,
dass es da nach wie vor meine Prognose, was was Gamada machen wird.
Mhm,
Gut. Weiter im Text. Ähm schalten wir jetzt schon nach Österreich oder wollen wir jetzt erst mal die USA äh.
Denke wir können eigentlich völlig egal wir können auch schon wir können auch erstmal die USA behandeln das ist ja mach mal die USA ja? Das ist ganz spannend in den USA,
gibt es ja ähm jetzt bald jeden Moment geht's los. Die Six Strikes Regelung,
Ja, wir kennen das, äh wir kennen den Begriff ja eigentlich eher unter, das heißt also irgendwie Provider äh Überwachung,
Verwarnung und Konvention bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen, also von Seiten des Providers soll man eine Warnung bekommen, dass man seinen Internetanschluss nicht im Sinne des Gesetzes oder im Sinne der,
Content-Industrie nutzt und ähm das bitte an, das Internet bitte anders benutzen soll.
Genau, man kriegt zwei Warnungen und beim dritten Mal ist man dann sozusagen auf die Straße.
Das war die, das war die das war die französische Regelung, wo dann also eine eine quasi mit dem H-Dopi-Gesetz äh eine äh,
Die Sanktionen sein sollte, dass man irgendwie kein Internet mehr hat. Ja, das war ja äh was hatten wir auch drüber gesprochen, dass das da bis jetzt noch nie wirklich passiert ist, dass jemand ernsthaft das Internet abgeknappt wurde? Äh da gibt's ja diese schönen ähm,
Schön zusammenrechnen, dass sie am Ende irgendwie einen Typen mal verknackt haben dazu, dass er gesagt hat, okay, ich mach's nicht mehr oder so. Und äh das ganze Ding ein paar Millionen gekostet hat oder so. Ähm in den USA wollen sie das ausweiten auf so eine sechs,
sechs Strikes Regelung, warum auch äh immer sechs äh wollen es wahrscheinlich wegen,
Systems die also was was gelingt ist was auftauchte war quasi ein,
internes Dokument, wie der Provider,
beabsichtigt umzusetzen mit diesen und dem was ist los? Das ist ihr Ernst.
Sorry,
Ist gerade was durch das Internet gekommen. Das war ein bisschen zu lustig. Ähm.
Okay, ähm denn der Tim surft nämlich hier nebenbei immer. Jetzt fange ich auch bald an, wie der Heu und beschwere mich. Also, die ähm,
Die USA wollen das machen. Alle großen Provider, wollen dieses diese Warnhinweismodell bei sich umsetzen und aufgetaucht ist das Dokument, in dem,
drin steht wie Horizon das machen möchte. Und das Schöne ist bei, also dass da mal ausformuliert zu sehen und zwar beim beim ersten und zweiten Mal bekommt man eine eine E-Mail und eine,
So einen automatischen Anruf. Kennst du das? So, hallo,
klingelt dann das Telefon, du gehst ran und äh da wird so eine Bandansage abgespiel.
Ja, so texte Beachmäßig.
Genau, wir haben so irgendwie so.
Wissen, wo sie wohnen.
Nee, wird dann so gesagt, so sie, ihr, ein Copyright Inhaber hat uns gesagt, dass von ihrem Anschluss äh irgendwie seine Rechte verletzt wurden.
Das ist doch, das ist doch wirklich geil. Das ist nicht nur die Privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung, das ist die Automatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Ja. Wunderbar. Ist geil.
Wunderbar.
So ein MEM Potential.
Ja ja. Das ist dann so ein bisschen, da fühlt man sich wahrscheinlich wie am Bahnhof mit diesen äh komischen Durchsagen, ne?
in fünf Minuten fährt auf Gleis sechs,
ein, der ICE fünf neun drei, ja, sowas, ne? Ist schön.
Genau, also und äh wird dann, also kriegst du einen Anruf, ja, ne, und ähm kriegst auch einen Link ähm,
um indem dir erklärt wird.
Wie du rausbekommen kannst.
Wie du die falsche installierst.
Super. Ja.
Ja? Äh.
Noch nicht wusste sozusagen.
Und wo wo man wo man legal äh solche Inhalte dann bekommen kann. Ja, es ist ja, wird so gesagt, so hier, wir zeigen dir, wir helfen dir dabei, das zu deinstallieren und sagen dir hier App,
Apple, iTunes oder so, ne.
Bei äh drei und vier, also beim dritten und vierten Mal äh begegnet dir der Provider mit der Manipulation deines Traffics und zwar,
In Form einer Browser-Umleitung. Das heißt, du gehst ans Internet, möchtest Gips irgendwie willst an den an den Anfang des Internets, Google Punkt com und.
Äh
Statt Google Punkt com kommt, dann äh Stoppschild Punkt com. Ähm,
Wo dann gesagt wird, so hier, ne, du ähm,
Wir haben dir ja schon mal gesagt, das ist nicht in Ordnung. Und diese Umleitung kommt solange, bis du bestätigst, dass du das gelesen hast und,
Lehrvideo geschaut hast, ja? Betont wird diese diese Bestätigung ist kein Schuldeingeständnis, ne? Also es,
ist nicht äh ist also quasi wie ohne Anerkennung einer Rechtspflicht äh bestätigst du, dass du das äh den Hinweis zur Kenntnis genommen und dieses dieses schöne Video ähm.
Wahrscheinlich ist so ein Klick auf einen Button, ist dann sozusagen ausreichend, ohne zu überprüfen, wer jetzt eigentlich gerade vor dem Bildschirm sitzt.
Ja natürlich, also auch wieder du kannst dir das vorstellen, ne? Der Provider hat einfach äh seine Regeln stehen, okay, jeder jeder Request von von diesem,
Subscriber wird umgeleitet bis ich bei mir in der Datenbank stehen habe, der hat OK geklickt.
Vermutlich ist dieses kleine Portal auch genauso äh schusssicher wie so. Login Portale in Hotels. Mhm,
So und wenn man dann immer noch böse ist.
Genau, das ist also vierter, dritter und vierter. Ähm und dann beim fünften und sechsten kommt wieder so ein Browser,
und da kannst du dann ähm aussuchen, ob du deine Speeddrosselung für direkt jetzt im die nächsten zwei bis drei Tage haben möchtest oder ob du sie irgendwann innerhalb der nächsten vierzehn Tage quasi positionieren möchtest.
sowie bei Führerschein, ne, dass sie sagen, wenn du jetzt, wenn sie sagen.
Sie müssen jetzt zwei Wochen mal den Lappen ab.
Zwei Wochen den Lappen abgeben, sie haben aber drei Monate Zeit, äh dreimal das Zeitfenster.
Wann, wann, wann sind sie denn im Urlaub?
Sind sie denn im Urlaub? So, da jetzt äh innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen musst du also quasi dann Urlaub nehmen, ja? Oder ähm oder du kannst diese ganze Angelegenheit,
Vor einem Schiedsmann anfechten. Also das ist glaube ich das, was die,
die die tatsächliche Übersetzung ist von von dem was sie also so quasi so eine Art Laienrichter oder so. Kannst du also vor den Schiedsmann ziehen und anfechten, dass du zwei bis drei Tage. Äh Internet wird, glaube ich, auf zweihundertsechsundfünfzig,
ähm pro Sekunde oder sowas gedrosselt. Also ein bisschen bisschen über ISM-Geschwindigkeit oder so.
Na ja, vierfacher. Aber das bezieht sich wahrscheinlich auch noch auf den Download.
Ja, vielleicht vielleicht habe ich's auch für.
Ob für ein Upload wahrscheinlich fünfundsiebzig äh Bit pro Sekunde.
Ja, genau, aber ist ja, also es ist schön so also,
dieser dieses äh Sie wollen Sie jetzt langsames Internet oder innerhalb der nächsten äh vierzehn Tage das irgendwo positionieren? Da liest man natürlich die Handschrift der äh,
Der Verbraucherschützer, ne, das hast du davon, wenn du, wenn du mit Verbraucherschützern äh redest und nicht mit ähm.
Was für ein Aufwand, man hätte ja auch einfach Bildschirmtext weiterlaufen lassen können, dann alternativ einfach die Leute auf Bildschirmtext umschalten, auf das Gleiche raus.
So sieht's auf jeden Fall aus. Ich ähm.
Und das ist jetzt was genau? Eine Idee.
Das ist das Konzept, was diesem.
Vorgeschlagen hat.
Was wohl umsetzen wird, das scheint ein internes Dokument zu sein, wie na das hatten wir, ähm da muss ich auf eine andere Sendung verlinken, das ähm,
die großen Provider in den USA, sich schon vor einiger Zeit geeinigt haben mit den ähm Rechteinhabern.
Dass wir das einfach machen.
Regelungen einzuführen.
Na großartig.
Ja, das ist also äh soweit ich weiß auch hier, da bin ich vorsichtig, da,
korrigiere ich mich entweder in der nächsten Sendung oder verweise auf jeden Fall nochmal auf die letzte, äh wo wir das Thema behandelt haben, nicht mit einer gesetzlichen Basis, sondern genau die,
quasi Absprache unter den Verbänden oder heißt das Verband, wenn wenn.
Verbände. Also das äh die Frage ist, wodurch wird das jetzt eigentlich getriggert, ja? Also ich meine, haben sie da jetzt automatisierte Systeme, die irgendwie äh äh das automatisch erkennen
oder geht das dann sozusagen wieder genauso über Anwälte, die äh sagen, hier da die IP-Adresse mach mal zu.
Es scheint ähm wann der Leser so zu sein, dass es immer noch äh so ist, dass die Provider,
sich äh dass die Rechteinhaber sich beim Provider beschweren.
Ich stelle mir das so vor, dass sie das automatisieren. Ich meine, die hängen ja ohnehin schon in jedem Schwarm mit drin.
äh dass sie da dann automatisch äh noch kurz gucken, zu welchem
Provider gehört diese IP und dann über eine dorthin melden, zack hier
in dem und dem Tor und der war in dem und dem Tor und der war in dem und dem Torent. Und dann gibt's da irgendwie so eine Art Bucket System bei den Provider, der dann sagt, okay, erste Verwarnung, zweite Verwarnung, ach so, der ist schon in der dritten, in der vierten Verwarnungsphase,
und gib ihm.
Na großartig.
So stelle ich mir das vor. Ähm.
Das heißt, es wird einfach passenhaft Warnungen geben. Ja, sie werden irgendwie auf alles Mögliche zeigen. Viele Leute werden Warnungen bekommen und Sperrungen erleiden müssen, obwohl sie wahrscheinlich gar nichts gemacht haben.
Einfach durch die typische Verdrehung von IP-Adressen und äh,
Et cetera, ja, weil das ja auch wieder die Zuarbeit der Provider äh et cetera, also selbst wenn es wenn es richtig funktioniert, wird's eine Menge Ärger bringen.
Die dreckige Variante wäre natürlich, dass der Provider auch die ähm die Überwachung macht. Äh das halte ich aber für äh aus, vor allem auch aus dem Grund für unwahrscheinlich, dass das,
so viel die PI-Infrastruktur der Provider nicht. Dafür aufwenden würde, ohne dass er da irgendwie finanzielles Modell.
Ja, es kostet ja auch Geld und vor allem äh vergraulen sie ihre Kunden damit, ne?
Ja und vor allem ähm wenn er selbst
Forschung macht, könnte auch haftbar sein, wenn er etwas nicht findet. Selbst wenn er sich das melden lässt, ist er da schön aus dem Schneider. Aber die ganze Sache zeigt recht schön, was passiert, wenn man keine klaren Gesetze der Netzneutralität hat.
weil das der Provider so mit der, mit der eigenen Internetleistung pfuschen kann und am Ende sogar einseitig die Vertragsbedingungen ändert, ich meine nichts anderes ist doch dieses runterregeln und in irgendwelche Container einsperren.
Ja und vor allem, was, was passiert? Ich meine, gerade in USA, wir kennen das, sind immer äh so Class-Action, immer sehr äh beliebt, ja, wenn sich dann erstmal so die ersten paar tausend Leute zusammentun, die ihrer Meinung nach äh falsch äh beschuldigt wurden, ja,
Ja, habe hier Sperrungen erleiden, meine meine Bandbreite wurde gedrosselt, das ist nicht das, wofür ich bezahle. Die Firma liefert mir nicht das, was mir zusteht, et cetera. Da muss
gleich erstmal wieder ein paar Millionen äh Schmerzgeld fließen, weil ich mich in meiner Datenausbreitung gestört gefühlt habe.
Ja, die werden's wahrscheinlich irgendwo in Teil, zum Teil ihrer AGBs machen oder so. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das im im Detail aussieht. Ich habe mich jetzt nur nochmal ganz schnell versichert, also die ähm,
Diese Anfechtung vor dem Schiedsmann ist natürlich auch dann gebührenpflichtig, kostete fünfunddreißig Dollar oder so.
ähm und das Ganze läuft, wie ich auch schon.
Sozusagen auch nochmal eine Revenue Generator dann.
Ja, unter Umständen, zumindest für diese Schiedsmänner. Und das Ganze äh,
ist außer, also nicht in innerhalb einer gesetzlichen Regelung, sondern eben eine von den, was ich ja auch für Deutschland,
eine Regelung unter den, unter den Anbietern selber und zwar äh unter den Providern und den Rechteinhabern, die sich zusammengeschlossen haben zum Center for Copyright Information.
Also es ist der Schiedsmann kostet Geld. Das ist wirklich super. Das ist dann, das ist jetzt sind wir wirklich wieder bei Brasilien,
der andere Film, der sich so mit vierundachtzig, da gibt's diese wunderbare Stelle, eine der tollsten Stellen überhaupt. Ja, irgendwie hinter diesem komplett, da steckt bestimmt dahinter, ja? Der war schon immer der Meinung, dass die Leute für ihre Verhöre mehr bezahlen sollten,
Und so ist es ja im Prinzip, ne? Ja,
Das ist echt äh bemerkenswert. Na gut, ähm.
Und das Ganze, also spannend. Ich will, ich will das nochmal betonen, ne? Ja. Ohne äh gesetzliche Grundlage, ja. Ähm die das machen die einfach, die haben sich da die großen Provider haben sich zusammengeschlossen, haben gesagt, das klingt doch nach einer guten Idee, was machen wir jetzt? Ähm,
Die US-Regierung billigt das, ja? Und geht davon aus, dass das einen signifikanten äh Einfluss haben wird,
Gibt's eine schöne ähm Bekanntgabe auf der Webseite des Weißen Hauses. Äh working together Internet Privace. Ich.
Aber es hat natürlich sicherlich auch eine gute Seite. Ich meine, wenn die Leute dann alle gedrosselt sind, dann dann gehen sie halt mehr raus an die äh frische Luft und kommen endlich mal wieder da zu ihrer automatischen Gewähre auszuprobieren.
Ja. Äh.
Äh
Es ist wirklich vielleicht über die zwei,
nochmal von der, das ist ja wirklich nicht mehr lustig, ne. Also äh Erziehungsvideos den Menschen aufzwingen, mit Bestätigung. Wahrscheinlich muss man am Ende noch einen Test zu dem Lehrvideo schreiben,
kreuzte sie an, äh das runterzuladen ist legal, illegal, scheißegal oder was. Keine Ahnung und äh,
Also wie, welche Macht musst du wirklich als Industrie in einem Land entfalten, dass Provider das für dich machen, ja? Dass Provider sagen, okay, wir,
wir kotzen unsere Nutzer so an,
Wir bauen diese gesamte Infrastruktur, wir wir beschneiden sie um den Dienst, die den wir ihnen anbieten. Wir stellen uns einerseits hin und werben,
mit irgendwelchen Bandbreiten dafür, für die den Leuten diesen Internetanschluss anzubieten und wir stellen uns dann hin und machen den den langsam.
Na, wahrscheinlich können sie äh hintenrum dann wiederum gute Deals einstreichen beim Verkaufen von Musik über Mobilfunk tralala et cetera.
Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Horizon.
Hatten wir ja auch schon hier mit.
Vielleicht hat Forisen ja, also das weiß ich nicht, vielleicht hat Verrison ja sowieso so einen MP3 Store oder wird gleichzeitig ein? Ich meine, das wäre die, das wäre einfach jetzt nur noch konsequent, ja, also wenn sie da nicht dran gedacht haben, dann äh,
Dann ist blöd, ne? Also dann muss.
Neues Management.
Da muss ein neues, ja da.
Uns mal anrufen.
Ja, wir müssen auf haben sie auf jeden Fall die falschen Berater,
Gehabt, ja. Na ja.
Na gut, das ist äh lass uns in das Land äh umschalten, wo äh Korruption und äh Rechtsverdrehung keine Realität ist. Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Niemals, niemals, das äh.
Gibt's denn Neues zu berichten?
Ach so viel, Avon, die zwei wichtigsten Sachen, die man erzählen sollte, ist, dass unser Verfassungsgerichtshof in Österreich sich mit unserer Klage beschäftigt hat, die der AKA Vorrat eingebracht hat
und zu einer sehr interessanten Entscheidung gekommen ist.
Also die Klage gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich. Mhm.
Genau,
und äh die Klage, die mir auch elftausend Leute mitgeklagt haben, die wird an den Europäischen Gerichtshof weitergereicht,
ähm prinzipiell teilt unser österreichischer Verfassungsgerichtshof ähm unserer Bedenken als Ackervorrat ähm sieht auch da,
eine Notwendigkeit, sich mit der Vereinbarkeit von Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Grundrechten auseinanderzusetzen?
und er stellt zwei Fragen an den Europäischen Gerichtshof. Die eine ist die, die wir schon kennen, das ist dieselbe Frage, die auch Irland schon an den EuGH gestellt hat.
ob die Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung prinzipiell mit der Grundrechte Charter der Europäischen Union vereinbar ist,
Das ist nix Neues, aber es ist trotzdem schon mal gut, wenn zwei Verfassungsgerichtshöfe dieselbe Frage an den EuGH stellen. Da könnte man hoffen, dass der dann vielleicht ein bisschen schneller arbeitet,
dauert ja sonst immer eineinhalb Jahre. Und die zweite Frage,
Die ist aber nochmal extra spannend, vor allem glaube ich für für Österreich und Deutschland in netzpolitischen Fragen.
Ich muss davor abschicken, wir haben beim Ackervorrat in Österreich wirklich gute Juristen, die haben da nämlich wirklich einen guten Hack geschafft. Ähm,
Das Ganze heißt Günstigkeitsprinzip. Äh und es ist eine Möglichkeit, wie man EU-Richtlinien aufheben könnte.
Günstig günstigst keit, Günstigkeitsprinzip, was heißt das?
Ja, was heißt das? Das ist ein ein, ein, ein Recht, was in den europäischen Grundrechten drinnen steht, die ja seit zweitausendneun
bindend sind. Ähm seit dem Vertrag von zweitausendneun haben wir alle europäische Grundrechte,
die definieren eben auch so Dinge wie Schutz des Familienlebens, des Privatlebens, Schutz der Korrespondenz, Dinge, die sehr wichtig sind ähm in Fragen der Netzpolitik
und einer dieser Grundsätze ist dieses Günstigkeitsprinzip. Untersagt ähm alles, was hier in den europäischen Grundrechten steht, ist schön und gut,
Aber wenn du nationale, verfassungsrechte hast, nationale Grundrechte.
Subjekt, also der Person, mehr Schutz geben, als das, was in den europäischen Grundrechten drinnen steht, dann kannst du die nationalen Gesetze verwenden. Und,
Genau dieses Günstigkeitsprinzip kann man nun anwenden und fragen so, wenn einer EU-Richtlinie gegen ein nationales Verfassungsgericht äh Verfassungsgesetz verstößt,
Grundrecht, was ihr in Deutschland oder wir hier in Österreich haben, gilt dann überhaupt diese EU-Richtlinie? Muss ich die dann überhaupt umsetzen?
Das wäre ein Weg, wie man sehr elegant äh die Umsetzung von kritischen EU-Richtlinien umgehen kann,
Rumänien hat genau dieses Prinzip schon verwendet, als der dortige Verfassungsgerichtshof mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung aufgehoben hat,
Und ähm ja, die Frage, wenn wir EuGH sich da wirklich in unserem Sinn entscheidet, dann wäre das ein Burner, weil damit könnte man wirklich Richtlinien abschießen.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, dieses Günstigkeitsprinzip besagt im Kern, äh wenn die nationale Verfassung ein Grundrecht äh garantiert,
Ist das als Grundrecht definiert? Ist das die richtige Terminologie an der Stelle? Ähm und das geht aber über,
Den Schutzbereich, den die europäische Verfassung äh definiert hinaus, also mehr Freiheit. Und dann kommt Europa und sagt
Naja, wir würden das jetzt gerne mal so im Rahmen unserer europäischen Maßstäbe irgendwie beeinflussen und man stellt dann fest, dass dann eben dieser erweiterte Schutz des nationalen Rechts taffon tangiert wird, dann,
geht es nicht. Eigentlich so eine Art Verfassungsvorbehalten genereller. Das ist aber jetzt auch nichts Neues, oder? Also.
Normalerweise ähm ist europäisches Recht immer vor jedem nationalen Recht.
Ja
Und.
Nicht bei Grundrechten oder wie oder nicht bei.
Ähm nein, normalerweise kannst du auch mit einer Richtlinie theoretisch äh das nationale Verfassungsrecht aushimmeln.
ähm nur ist es eben jetzt so, dass du äh die die europäischen Grundrechte gelten natürlich vor den europäischen Richtlinien oder den Verordnungen,
äh und damit äh hast du einen einen eben diesen Umweg, wo du die Richtlinie selbst zumindest für deinen Start ausheben könntest.
und die Frage haben wir deswegen in die Klage reingeschrieben, weil wir diese Möglichkeit gesehen haben. Und auch die Frage hat unser Verfassungsgerichtshof jetzt eben an Europa weitergereicht.
Entschieden ist jetzt sozusagen noch gar nichts.
Nee, nee, nee, also wir haben jetzt mal die die Klarkschrift äh nach Straßburg geschickt ähm oder vor der AGH. Ich glaube, den Haag oder so, irgendwo da oben. Und ja, der braucht wahrscheinlich so eineinhalb Jahre, bis er entschieden hat.
Das ist so zumindest der Durchschnitt, den der EuGH sich für seine Entscheidungen nimmt.
So lange stehen wir hier auf Hold und ähm ja, unser Verfassungsgericht so wird's nicht tun. Wir haben weiter Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähm warten,
auf die Gerichte.
Und ist denn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ähm auch schon wirklich aktiv? Also ich meine, es ist äh voll heißt es, dass es auch wirklich überall umgesetzt worden ist.
Also seit ersten April ähm gibt's die Speicherverpflichtung für alle Provider,
über einer gewissen Größe sind und ähm ja, die müssen dann eben die die pauschalen äh Verbindungsdaten aller ihrer Kunden aufzeichnen für sechs Monate.
und äh ja. Wir hoffen jetzt dann bald mal äh ordentliche Statistiken zu bekommen darüber, wie diese Daten verwendet wurden, weil das steht bei uns eigentlich auch ein Gesetz drin, aber da habe ich noch nichts gesehen,
und ähm ja, seit ersten April leider. Und schaut so aus, als würde uns die Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch noch eine längere Zeit begleiten.
Okay. Und du hast jetzt noch ein zweites äh Thema erwähnt, was du noch äh einbringen wolltest?
Was auf jeden Fall auch grad sehr hoch kocht in Österreich, ist die Debatte um das Urheberrecht,
da gibt's einen geliebten Gesetzesentwurf der sehr hanebüchende Vorschläge macht zum Beispiel was ganz stark diskutiert wird ist eine eine Festplattenabgabe,
Das heißt, äh alle Speichermedien sollen teurer werden, egal ob das ähm hartisk sind, es ist dies, ähm,
egal, wo das äh Speichermedium verbaut ist, ob das irgendwie ein Wecker ist oder ein Telefon, äh die wollen dann mal pauschal überall ähm,
Urheberrechtsabgaben drauf einheben, also das, was vorher die Festplattenabgabe war, da erkennt man's vielleicht noch oder die die Kassettenabgabe war früher.
Ähm das äh ist so einer der Punkte, das heißt, dass äh die Dinge teurer werden, die Elektronikartikel teurer werden. Und auf der anderen Seite steht da sowas drin, wie wir wollen Vorratsdaten verwenden, um Urheberrechtsdelikte aufzuklären,
Also wir wollen auf die Vorratsdaten zugreifen, wenn wir glauben, dass da die IP-Adresse hier,
ähm urheberrechtlich geschütztes Lied runtergeladen hat oder sonst irgendetwas, was ein ein Abmahnanwalt als ähm rechtswidrig ansieht,
Im Moment ist es ja so bei uns in Österreich, dass du nicht so leicht ähm in einem Zivilverfahren herausfinden kannst, wer hinter einer P-Adresse ist,
Ähm dazu brauchst du einen Staatsanwalt im Allgemeinen,
und das wollen sie kippen, sodass du auch äh als ganz normaler Anwalt, ohne dass du ein Offiziersdelikt hast, hergehen kannst und herausfinden, wer ist hinter dieser IP-Adresse, damit ich der Person Brief schicken kann und die Abmahnung zustellen kann.
Ist ganz lustig, weil sie haben das auch gleich.
Aber äh brauchst dafür wirklich jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil ich meine, das geht ja auch in äh äh Deutschland sozusagen einfach durch den Zugriff auf Logfile. Es ist ja sozusagen nur wem welchem Anschluss wurde die IP-Adresse äh rausgegeben
das erfordert ja sozusagen keine keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Hier bezieht sich das jetzt schon explizit da drauf, oder?
Ähm tut es, weil sie auch extra sagen, so für drei Monate. Wir wollen, dass diese Daten für drei Monate von Provider gespeichert werden und sozusagen dann auch noch ähm zweieinhalb Monate zurückschauen können, äh wer diesen Torentruntergeladen.
Und das ist denn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich nicht genau so äh eingeführt worden mit dem Hinweis, äh dass man ja nur die schwersten aller Schwerden Verbrechen und größten aller denkbaren Delikte.
Natürlich, das war eine Antiterrormaßnahme, die man unbedingt gebraucht hat für die Sicherheit. Und jetzt wird sie auf einmal.
Terror nimmt ja auch wirklich Überhand in Österreich.
Echt? Ich merke davon nichts.
Achso, ich dachte, äh bei euch brennen eigentlich die ganze Zeit die Straßen.
Nein, wir wir verurteilen Politiker. Wir haben gerade einen ehemaligen Innenminister ins Gefängnis gesteckt. Also ich.
Oh, ach das sind die Terroristen.
Ja, dieser Strasser, genau, wie die Terroristen, die.
Ist der auf Basis der Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh überführt worden.
Nein, nein, nein, viel lustiger. Es gab ein Video von zwei britischen Journalisten, die ihn beim äh sich selbst als Lobbyist verkaufen überführt haben. Das hat.
Als Lobbyist für was?
Äh ist Europaabgeordneter und hat dazu gemeint, ja für hunderttausend Euro im Jahr ähm.
Mal, ja, okay, alles klar, das habe ich sogar gesehen, ja, ja. Oh.
Ich schicke euch einen Link zu den YouTube-Videos. Sehr unterhaltsam.
Warum habt ihr euch den nicht gekauft um die Vorratsdaten sprech.
Hätte man doch sammeln können. Crowdfunding.
Ihr seid doch blöd. Da habt ihr so einen einfachen Einstieg, so hoch in die Politik. Und was macht ihr, bringt den Typen ins Knast? Also ist auch undankbar.
Genau, das wäre doch einfach mal man macht einfach Crowdfunding zur Bestechung von korrupten Politikern, damit sie äh die richtigen Gesetze beschließen.
Hunderttausend Euro hätte, dann würde ich sie lieber Etri geben.
Gut. Wir scherzen.
Ähm ja,
äh also wie gesagt, Urheberrecht, da stehen grobe Dinge drin wie Festplattenabgabe, diese diese VDS, also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Urberrechtsdelikte ist einfach Hanebüchen, weil ich meine,
Verfassungsgerichtshof sagt, das ist das geht nicht und dann gleichzeitig wirst du's ausweiten.
Also Festplattenabgabe, das ist sozusagen im Prinzip dieser typische äh äh was ja hier in Deutschland,
eigentlich fast also ich bin mir sogar sicher, dass wir das bei Festplatten auch haben, oder Linus, weißt du da was.
Ja, ja, die wurde ja auch in Deutschland er.
Genau, ne? Also hier muss ja alles, alles was in irgendeiner Form in der Lage ist, ein Bit zu reproduzieren, USB-Sticks, äh äh Kopierer schon seit Jahr und Tag, ja, gibt's immer wieder diese äh Abgaben, äh grad habe ich gelesen, dass die GEMA auch noch irgendwie fünfunddreißig
Euro von jedem iPhone einstreicht, was in Deutschland verkauft wird, also unbestätigt, aber so habe ich das gelesen. Also es sind so,
Diese ganzen ha, naja, da könnte man ja Schabernack mitreiben und so weiter, gibt uns mal Geld und dann wird aber trotzdem noch draufgehauen, das finde ich eigentlich das Perfide
da dran, ja? Dass man sich an der Stelle nicht dann auch damit zufrieden gibt, dass man sagt, okay alles klar, wir wissen, das wird hier irgendwie getradet, äh pipapo äh
pfeifen im Walde, äh gibt Kohle und dann sind wir ruhig, ne? Und allen stattdessen muss nochmal extra drauf rumgehauen werden.
Ich meine, so eine Festplattenabgabe ist kann ja auch eine gute Sache sein
wenn du damit die Privatkopie stärkst, wenn du damit sagst ja gut ihr zahlt extra etwas für eure Festplatten, aber dafür könnt ihr damit auch machen, was ihr wollt.
das ist private Nutzung und ist abgegolten, passt. Aber das passiert ja eben nicht. Wir müssen mehr zahlen und gleichzeitig werden wir leichter kriminalisiert.
Ja, der ist weniger um die Privatkopie zu stärken, als mehr den Privaturlaub von äh den.
Ja also das es,
es, ich denke, der der Widerspruch, den Thomas da gerade genau rausarbeitet ist hier das Entscheidende. Wir hatten ja in der letzten Sendung ähm ein ein ähnlichen Sachverhalt, nämlich der mit dem
abgeschlossenen Thema des Schultrojaners, dass man quasi eine, dass sie Schulbuchverlage eine Pauschale,
von neun Millionen bekommen dafür, dass sie tolerieren das in gewissem Ausmaß Fotokopien von ihren Büchern gemacht.
Dass sie das, was sie gekauft haben, auch noch benutzen.
In den Kommentaren jemanden, der betont hat, dass äh dass dies dass das ja nicht dass das ja weit über Benutzung hinausgeht, das zu kopieren oder so, aber so, sagen wir mal, dass im im Unterricht nutzen, ja, dass ein Lehrer ein Lehrbuch im Unterricht nutzen kann,
ohne, dass alle seine Schüler etwas kaufen, ja, also dass er jetzt vielleicht der Anwendungsfall vielleicht,
Die Lehre ein besonderes Lehrbuch, was äh an seiner Schule nicht hat. Da hat er eine Aufgabe drin, die möchte er kopieren, ähm da damit überschreitet er nicht äh zwanzig Seiten oder zehn Prozent des Buches. Und deswegen kann es mit den Leuten teilen,
Diese Pauschale mit diesen ganzen Einschränkungen klingt ja gegenüber einer Festplattenabgabe plus komplett Illegalisierung,
Alle all dessen, wofür du diese ähm Festplatte zahlst, noch fast human. Ja, also das ähm,
Warte, lass mal überlegen, gibt's nicht irgendeinen, irgendwas, was man mit der Festplatte machen kann, was legal ist und diese,
Abgabe dann rechtfertigen würde, nicht wirklich, oder?
Fällt mir jetzt nichts ein. Also du du könntest sie theoretisch auch zurückverlangen, wenn du nachweisen kannst, dass du sie nicht verwendet hast, um urheberrechtlich geschützte Wer.
Kann man das tatsächlich? Kann man das tatsächlich.
Nee, kannst du natürlich nicht. Das ist hanebüchen, weil du da äh wie wie willst du nachweisen, dass du eine Festplatte nicht verwendet hast, um,
irgendwas, von dem du nicht mit dem Fingerprint hast, drauf zu speichern.
Aber es gab doch, warte mal, es gab zumindest bei der GEMA gab es in der, in dem alten Tarif äh so etwas wie,
Eine Zusatzgebühr, die du bezahlen musst, wenn du gebrannte Rohlinge verwendest.
Also in in deiner Kneipe, ich kenne das jetzt von der Kneipe. Die Kneipe war zahlte quasi nur für das Abspielen von tatsächlich gekaufter Musik. Wenn du das Recht haben möchtest, auch MP3s abzuspielen,
oder gebrannte Rohlinge? Dann musstest du mehr bezahlen,
Ähm ich glaube, die Begründung war nicht, dass damit die äh die äh die Raubkopie quasi,
der hinten durch die Tür wieder äh kompensiert oder legalisiert wird, sondern dass du dadurch das zusätzliche Recht hast, äh oder die zusätzliche Möglichkeit hast, deine Musik selber zusammenzustellen.
Hm. Nee, aber das das Interessante an.
Also du wärst, du wärst quasi immer noch drangekommen, wenn du da eine gebrannte CD in der Kneipe hast, weil die darfst du ja nicht darfst ja nicht brennen. Also.
Ja eben, das das Interessante ist hier äh du hast halt überhaupt keinen Ausgleich, also die,
Die Befürworter von diesem Urheberrechtspaket
argumentieren das alles mit ja die armen Künstler. Die brauchen hier unbedingt äh mehr Geld, deswegen brauchen wir eine Festplattenabgabe. Äh Kassetten gibt's nicht mehr und deswegen ist das die logische Konsequenz. Und äh ihr kennt vielleicht noch alle Kunst hat Recht.
Die waren auch auf dem ähm Netzpolitik Punkt ORG, öfter mal Thema. Ähm das ist so eine eine Astro Törfing Gruppierung, die
hauptsächlich aus der Unterhaltungsindustrie finanziert wird äh mit so Lobby in PR-Firma dahinter und aber so tut, als würde sie die Interessen der Künstler vertreten
und das fliegt langsam auf. Das ist sehr schön zu sehen, wie die immer mehr unter Beschuss geraten von,
etablierten, wirklichen Künstlervertretungen, einfach weil das, was die da fordern, in diesem Urheberrechtspaket auch nach deren Meinung eigentlich nicht geht,
und ähm das ist gerade ganz lustig, weil wir wir haben ja auch bald Wahl im September,
und dass ähm eskaliert gerade sehr schön und du siehst, wie ähm das Astro Turfing überhand nimmt und und wir haben jetzt auch irgendwie die Wirtschaft, die
sich mit einem eigenen Verein zu Wort meldet und es gibt zwei unterschiedliche Bürgerinitiativen, die diese Woche gestartet wurden
Eine für die Festplattenabgabe, eine dagegen äh und und ja. Das ist sehr unterhaltsam, aber auch ähm ja sehr dramatisch, wenn das Gesetz in der Form durchkommt,
Auch ein letzter Punkt noch drin ist, nämlich der Verbot, das Verbot von Downloads aus offensichtlich illegalen Quellen,
Steht da auch so einfach drin und man kann sich nur fragen, was sind offensichtlich illegale Quellen?
Ja. Wer steht denn eigentlich hinter dieser Initiative dieses Gesetzesentwurfs? Also wer hat denn das äh wer hat denn das losgetreten? Wer vertritt das.
Also, das äh Papier, was wir jetzt haben, kommt aus dem Justizministerium, das gerade unter der Leitung von unserer,
ÖVP, unserer konservativen schwarzen Partei ist. Und es ist auch die ÖVP, die am stärksten für eine Verschärfung des Urheberrechts eintritt und die am
ähm am meisten auf Linie der Unterhaltungsindustrie in diesen Fragen ist. Ähm ja
Die haben da hauptsächlich die den Vorstoß gemacht und und und treffen sich auch sehr gerne mit den äh relevanten Playern von der Gegenseite. Und ähm
Es formiert sich aber eben Widerstand. Du hast jetzt auch andere Parteien, die schon anfangen damit Wahlkampf zu machen, dagegen zu sein und die SPÖ, die hier im Moment noch den Kanzler stellt und in der Regierung ist, die Bank so ein bisschen, die hat sich letztens, haben sich da ein paar Leute dagegen ausgesprochen
und andere sind noch dafür. Ja, das wird man sehen.
Das heißt, die die SPÖ, die den Kanzler stellt, ist gar nicht die Triebfeder dahinter, sondern das.
Nee, die sind in der Koalition, wir haben genauso SPÖ und ÖVP.
Und die FPÖ. Okay, aber äh sind sozusagen noch nicht davon überzeugt oder äh ist das sozusagen so Koalitionsresort mit, wir tragen das jetzt einfach mal mit, ohne drüber nachzudenken.
Unterscheiden die Ministerin die Verantwortliche, die ähm Kunst und Kulturministerin, die ist dafür, die hat sich schon dafür ausgesprochen.
Und die ist von der äh SPÖ oder was? Mhm.
Ähm und und äh es gibt soeben wir haben ja in Österreich keine Netzpolitik, aber wir haben Netzpolitiker,
Wir haben das Thema nicht in den Parteien, es gibt da keine offiziellen Sprecher, aber es
einzelne Personen, die das thematisch besetzen, die teilweise auch sehr viel Ahnung haben und die auch wirklich versuchen, was zu bewegen, aber die haben halt in ihrer Partei nicht immer das Gewicht, dass das ihnen zustehen würde,
Die Netzpolitikerin, die ist da dafür in der SPÖ, die Sonja Ablinger. Und auch andere, aber ja, man wird sehen, ob das hält innerhalb der Partei. Ich meine, die haben da sogar auf drei Tagesbeschluss in die Richtung, aber wir werden's sehen.
Wen das interessiert, ich äh will da auch mal irgendwie äh Netzpolitik Punkt Ork Artikel schreiben. Und Leonard Dubus hat das letztens auch sehr gut aufgedröselt. Äh wir verlinken da drauf.
Ja, Linus, letzter Punkt.
Wir bleiben beim beim Urheberrecht für Leute, die nicht wirklich Urheber sind.
Ja, für Leute, die nicht genug kriegen können.
Und zwar ähm finde ich das sehr äh habe ich ein ein völlig normalen Satz völlig normalen Satz in in deutschen Medien, völlig normaler Satz, den man sich mal so auf der Zunge zergehen lassen muss,
Lobbyisten, der Axel Springer AG haben sich im Kanzleramt,
fünf Monate vor der Bundestagswahl zweitausendneun für ein Leistungsschutzrecht für Pressevorlage.
Fünf Monate vor der Wahl, kommt der mächtigste äh Zeitungsverlag ins Kanzleramt und sagt,
Hör mal Jungs, uns fällt da ein, äh wir hätten da noch so eine kleine Vorstellung da,
Wäre doch ganz gut, wenn das dann Ende zweitausendneun im Herbst zweitausendneun in der Koalitionsvereinbarung stehen würde, wo es natürlich dann auch gelandet ist. Ähm,
ist rausgekommen auf äh auf eine Anfrage der Linken. Ähm,
Und wir erinnern uns, dass ja äh Netzpolitik Orga in die in diese Richtung auch eine äh Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage gestellt hatte, was nämlich die,
auf die Brüder von von Kläden abzielte.
die zurückgewiesen wurde mit der Begründung äh,
die Antwort auf die Frage könnte den Erfolg der Entscheidung beeinträchtigen, ja? Ähm wir berichteten. Jetzt äh stellt sich also raus, diese Lobbyisten, die dort äh im Kanzleramt waren, waren also der,
Cheflobbyist Dietrich von Gläden sowie unser bereits bekannter Christoph Käse, der,
bei Heise dann als der Außenminister des Konzerns bezeichnet wird.
Und dieser Dietrich von Kleen und der Christoph Käse gehen also fünf Monate vor der äh Wahl rein und nach der Wahl, wie wir wurde dann völlig überraschend Eckart von Kläden, der Bruder des,
Axel Springer Lobbyisten, Staatsminister bei der Kanzlerin Merkel,
Da geendet die Geschichte aber schon, denn dieser Bruder der Cheflobby ist Dietrich von Kleender, im Kanzleramt für das Leistungsschutzrecht lobbyiert,
hatte natürlich niemals mit irgendwelchen Leistungsschutzrechtsangelegenheiten zu tun. Insofern, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen.
Bitte weitergeben. Mhm.
Nettes äh diese Fragestellung hatte ja Sascha Lobo schon vor längerer Zeit äh ich glaube ähm ausm Spiegel seiner Kolumne oder war das in seinem Blog? Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, wo der Artikel stand. Ähm die Frage schon mal aufge.
Mhm.
Gibt's aber jetzt sozusagen nur die neue Erkenntnis, dass es natürlich alles nichts miteinander zu tun.
Hat alles nichts miteinander zu tun, wir können beruhigt sein, die Brüder von Kleden, die zwar beide da äh
offensichtlich den Fokus ihrer Arbeit im Bundeskanzleramt hatten. Der eine, weil er dort arbeitete, der andere, weil er dort lobbyierte, ähm haben da,
niemals äh irgendwas miteinander zu tun gehabt.
Ja, wie konnten wir nur auf die Idee kommen.
Nee, also es ist halt was man in solchen Fällen ja immer sagt, ist, dass es man kritisiert ja dann, dass es ähm,
Das Vertrauen in die Politik schwächt, wenn man sich so verhält, als,
Natürlich haben die sich da so nicht haben die klare Stillschweigen darüber bewahrt. Niemals miteinander übers Leistungsschutzrecht gesprochen, obwohl der eine Staatsminister ist. Niemals, nur.
Schon gar nicht unter Brüdern.
Schon gar nicht unter Brüdern, ne, die haben ja sowieso Streit. Der eine hat den anderen ja auch immer verhauen, als sie klein waren. Insofern die ähm,
Es liegt das nur so nah, ne? Und das ist, ne, also man, das Einzige, was man da kritisieren kann, ist, dass das natürlich die Politikverdrossenheit im Lande äh.
Fördert, wenn man so überhaupt so eine Idee aufbringt. Ja. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber mehr haben die sich da nicht vorzuwerfen. Das muss betont werden.
Bitte weitergeben. Ja und wir gehen auch weiter.
Wir gehen auch weiter.
So richtig jetzt so ein äh Feuerwerk abgebrannt, haben wir jetzt nicht zur Fünfzigsten, ne?
Ne äh.
Haben wir auch nicht.
Äh nee, das ist ja, das Thema ist ja auch alles hier äh ernst, ernstes Geschäft und äh wir können nicht äh hier jedes Mal äh Halligalli machen, ne? Das ist einfach.
Machen, das stimmt.
Ihr müsst öfter mit Publikum machen, mehr Live-Sendungen.
Ja. Da hast du recht.
Livesendungen, ja, finde ich auch gut.
Kann man daran arbeiten,
Ja und wir müssen vor allem mal hier auch die schweizerische äh Perspektive einholen. Da müssen wir unser Korrespondentennetz noch äh ein wenig erweitern, ja, in der letzten Sendung haben wir uns ja jetzt schon nach Brüssel äh hin ausgedehnt,
ja, Lokbuch-Netzpolitik äh auch als europäisches Projekt, ja. Streben wir einfach da äh die Heronie an im Medienbereich.
Ja, ich äh vielleicht sollen wir es auch echt einmal explizit ja sagen, also jemand aus der Schweiz fehlt uns. Ich habe da auch ähm glaube ich jetzt, mir fällt da wirklich keiner ein. Also ich würde mich äh über.
Tipps und Ratschläge und Hinweise.
Durchaus freuen, die da äh.
Hinweise, die zur Ergreifung eines Korrespondenten in der Schweiz führen könnten.
Will.
Melden Sie bitte, rufen Sie bitte jetzt an.
Genau, würde mich sehr freuen.
Die Nummer äh unter ihrer Landesflagge an.
Oder äh kontaktieren sie Tim oder mich auf Twitter oder App dot net?
Oder auf irgendeinem anderen Kanal, der äh euch äh genehm erscheint. Und dann äh werden wir das an die zuständigen Behörden weiterleiten. So sieht's mich aus. Du hast auch keinen Tipp, Thomas.
Ich habe letztens ein paar Schweizer kennengelernt von äh dem neu gegründeten CCC dort,
Aber es wäre natürlich gut, wenn man jemanden, der irgendwie so podcaffin ist, dort hätte, der auch das Equipment hat. Ähm aber mir fällt noch niemand ein.
Ja, na gut, wir arbeiten dran.
Noch mehr deutsche Hegemonie, das heißt, ihr seid dann das Netzpolitik Leitmedium für ganz Europa. Oh mein Gott.
Für die ganze Welt.
Tausendjährige Leitmedium.
Na ja.
B.
Lassen wir es nicht zu sehr abgleiten. Thomas, vielen Dank für äh deinen Beitrag,
äh hat jetzt hier auch äh technisch mal ganz hervorragend funktioniert hier, voll multimedial, ich bin beeindruckt und ja, nächste Woche schließen wir uns wieder zusammen, das heißt,
morgen die Nuss.
Ciao, Tim.
Tschü tschü.